But, if love is a thing that we can define,...
...then how can it mean opposite things for so many people?
So, maybe love's all just in your head,...
...a personal mystery winding through your neural pathways...
...and lighting up pleasing, natural rewards in your nervous system.
Perhaps these rewards are addictive.
Perhaps love is a temporary or permanent addiction to a person,...
...just like a person can be addicted to a drug.
I don't mean to be edgy like some pop song.
Evidence shows that chemicals in your brain stimulated by another person...
...can make you develop a habit for that person.
That person comes to satisfy a physiological craving, and you want more.
But then sometimes, slowly or suddenly, you don't.
You've fallen out of love, become unaddicted, for a spell.
What happened?
Does one develop a tolerance or hit a limit?
Why do some lovers stay addicted to each other their entire lives?
Perhaps to create new lives, to proliferate their species.
Maybe love is just human DNA's optimal method...
...for bringing about its own replication.
There are evolutionary arguments regarding every human mating behavior,...
...from how we display ourselves to potential mates,...
...to how we treat each other in relationships, to how we raise kids.
Thus, some argue that the feeling you think you feel in your soul...
...is just biology's way to make you continue our species.
Nature has selected you to have crushes on hotties...
...just like it makes monkeys have crushes on hot monkeys...
...and biology marches on.